[MUSIC PLAYING]
Services are an
integral component
for almost every
Android application,
but the functionality
they provide
comes with a drain on
battery and system resources.
And if you're not
paying attention,
they can get a little
greedy with that, too.
My name is Colt
McAnlis, and using
services in the most
efficient way possible
means killing them
off the right way
and sometimes not
even using them.
Remember, services are how
an application indicates
to the operating
system that it needs
to perform a longer
running operation outside
of normal activity UI flow.
Basically, you can
do work and don't
have to wait for
input events to do it.
Which is all great, but
there's a few things
you need to be aware of.
Firstly, that from a
system-level, services
aren't free.
Creating, scheduling, running,
and even destroying services
costs time and memory.
Secondly, services
run on the UI thread
of your application,
which is trying
to update the screen every
16 milliseconds or so.
This means if you're doing a
bunch of work in a service,
you can easily miss that
16 millisecond window
and end up dropping a frame.
Now, let me be very
clear about this.
In 90% of the cases, the best
way to avoid these issues
is to not use a service.
In fact, there's a
lot of situations
where services are being used
when they don't need to be.
For example, using a service
to listen and respond to events
is way overkill.
APIs like BroadcastReceiver can
still respond fine to events
even when your app is
running in the background.
This goes double for
spinning up a service just
to poll a server for data.
Again, bad idea.
You should be leveraging
Google Cloud Messaging instead
to allow the server to push
updates to you which you can
still receive in your app
directly without needing
a service running.
And if you know
that your work is
going to be happening
in the background,
then it doesn't make sense
to bother the framework
to be scheduling
services for you.
Instead, try using an
actual threading setup,
like IntentServices, or
[? HandlerThreads, ?]
or Async Task
Loaders, all of which
will get you the same result
but with less scheduling
overhead on the system,
and actually get
your things off the UI thread.
Which is a bonus, as well.
Basically, there's lots
of options provided
by the framework to do various
types of asynchronous work
without needing to resort to the
overhead that services demand.
So if you can, try to leverage
one of those solutions first.
But if you've exhausted
all of those options
and you still find that
a service is the only way
to solve the problem,
then you need
to adhere to the one
primary rule of services--
do not let services live
longer than they are needed.
You've got to remember there's
two distinct types of services
with two distinct ways
to terminate them.
See, started services stay
alive until they are explicitly
stopped with a stopSelf
or stopService call,
or your app ends.
Until then, the
service just sits
around waiting to process
things and eating up resources.
Now, a bound service,
on the other hand,
stays around and
consumes system resources
until all of its clients
unbind from it by calling
unbindService or your app ends.
Now, mixing these two
services is useful
but it's a common
source of errors.
For example, calling
[? startService ?]
to create your service
and then calling
bindService on it for
IPC communication.
The problem here
is that even when
the client calls
unbindService, it
won't terminate yet
because it's waiting around
for a stopService to be called.
The gist is this-- you must get
your pairing of start, stop,
bind, and unbind right before
this service will actually
terminate, and basically,
that's the trick with services.
Avoid them if you can.
And if you are using them,
make sure that you're not
letting them ramble off
into the weeds for longer
than they should be.
And if you have a suspicion
that your services might
be doing that, Systrace
is a great visual tool
to help you see where
your system time is going
and what apps are
responsible for it.
And that's what Android
Performance Patterns are all
about-- making sure you're
doing the right things
at the right times so that you
don't waste resources or perf
cycles.
Which is why you should check
out the rest of the Android
Performance Patterns content.
And don't forget to join our
Google+ community for tips from
other great developers.
So keep calm, profile your
code, and always remember
perf matters.
[MUSIC PLAYING]